so it's my pleasure to introduce our
first speaker dr. Robert Grossman he is
the director of the Center for
data-intensive sciences and a professor
in the division of Biological Sciences
at the University of Chicago he is a
core faculty and senior fellow at the
Institute of genomics and systems
biology and the computation institute he
is also the founder and a partner of
open data group which has been building
predictive models over big data for
fortune 500 companies since 2002 his
topic and title of his presentation
today is big data and analytics five
trends and five challenges please join
me in welcoming dr. Grossman
[Applause]
let's see do I it's how do I shift to
the to the PowerPoint deck ok
we're switching to your computer i take
it right yeah are you DJ okay thank you
okay well it's a real pleasure to be
here i'm going to talk i'm going to give
a high-level talk about Big Data I'm
going to assume you know nothing about
it but assume you care a little bit
about it I the term big data like cloud
computing doesn't mean anything anymore
the simple way to tell when the term
doesn't mean anything is if you're in an
airport and waiting for your luggage and
you see a term like cloud computing or
big data than from a research
perspective you see the term say in a
large advertisement that's 10 feet by 20
feet then that's a really a good sign
that that term doesn't mean anything
from a research perspective and so a big
data is like that it this is a 2012
report big data big impact from the
World Economic Forum where they're
talking about how big data is going to
impact the developing world so it's it's
it's a nice term to use and we're going
to but I'm going to try to die down a
little bit into it so the tradition the
other the other way to sort of realize
that you know there's a certain
trajectory determine is when the term
appears on the cover of magazines like
science nature the economist and
scientific america and here are some
covers the traditional way of looking at
big data is to is to measured in terms
of bites like megabytes or petabytes and
if you it's you know if you go to a
conference in data and people have a
couple beers you hear them complaining
that when they reach a certain level of
petabytes their file system stopped
working there interconnect stopped
working and so on so there's clearly an
issue as you get more bites that certain
things begin to break the
the other way because the poeple
popularize subjects they like
alliteration two is to talk about data
in terms of how much there is how fast
it moves how what the variety it is etc
and so there's nothing wrong with either
of these methods but they miss a little
bit about what's associated and has
transitioned in big data and I saw I
want to dive a little bit further the
simplest way to think of data is that
you know we always have data we always
will we'll always have people who can do
something with it and we'll always have
people who throw up their hands and
complain and what does change is every
few years the terms change so I've been
in the business since for about 30 35
years and so I see more or less the same
problems I do notice there's an ebb and
flow to the meetings i go to sew around
96 to 2001 there was a sort of a real
interest in large data and that was
associated around the term data mining
and knowledge discovery and of starting
a few years ago maybe five years ago
there was a sort of a resurgence of
interest but more or less there's been a
continuous trajectory as we've changed
the terms what you see on the Google
Trends is the blue is the term data
mining or knowledge discovery and the
red is the term big data so if you look
at this sum of those two terms nothing
has changed but we use the term slightly
differently now I do think certain
things have changed but it really is not
whether you call it data mining
statistics or knowledge discovery or
predictive analytics a cheatin on I were
just talking and if you want a different
perspective on data go to a conference
called strata you can't believe anything
you hear at that conference unlike other
conferences where everything they say is
absolutely true with no exaggeration but
it's still important to go to a
conference like that because it fills
sort of a large exhibit
what floor the size of a football field
and they're all doing things and sort of
one of the things different there is
they all many of them come from
companies where they have a lot of data
and they get fired if they do stupid
things with it so there's a certain
Darwinian evolution that takes place
it's hard to you know not ever the
density of people who know what's going
on is maybe not that great but there are
a lot of them there that know a lot in
this definition is not a bad working
definition for big data today data is
big today if it's too big for your IT
group to help you work with it and if
you need something else then you know
the data is big so you know depending
upon whether your google or whether
you're a social science lab with you
know doesn't even get a data closet you
know that the size will change but the
problem remains that you know that you
have a problem with your day with
managing your data I think one of the
real things that does change and this is
because of you know the same law that
drives commoditization of processors you
know moore's law that gives us every
18-24 months you know that may change in
a few years but right now we have a
tremendous increase in our processing
power of and so we can do a level of
compute in every two years that is just
sort of unmanageable several years
before that that same commoditization
impact sensors and so you have sensors
be putting out more and more data at
lower and lower costs and then you know
compliant if ax communities is we're
going to discuss organize their sensors
differently but in each case the
scientific communities organize their
sensors and put out data and that's
impacting the data we see in research
that I think perhaps the the most
fundamental transformation is every
decade or sold the way we use these
sensors changes and we get incredibly
new modalities of data so when I started
sort of doing commercial large big data
in the
the mid 90s there was internet click
data and points of transaction data and
no one knew how to analyze it and people
basically created what now are called
Beowulf clusters they created clusters
of computers they created new
statistical techniques like ensembles of
models which fit very well over clusters
of computers and over time they were
able to analyze data at that scale
around 2000 a whole nother type of data
came out which is the unstructured text
data on the on the web and then again
what emerged was sort of the MapReduce
style of that google introduced to
analyze large unstructured data that
comes up in search and that was actually
a fundamental change and then what's
going on now is there's yet another
transformation in which things are
moving from the internet to the to
mobile and Internet of Things and that's
creating a third revolution now one of
the underlying themes here is none of
these revolutions are from the
scientific side and in each of these
cases for whatever reasons not only did
the ten or a hundred or thousand fold
increase in data come from the industry
side but the new techniques in terms of
hardware and software stacks came from
there too and in each case at least in
my experience the research lags and then
picks up these techniques sometimes a
few years later but more often a decade
later and so you know the transition
where a number of years ago a high
performance computing and simulation
would lead you see in data science that
researchers by and large foul and that's
for the simple reason that if you are
hired by a large internet or mobile
company today you will have
responsibility for working with very
large data sets with no nonsense you
know ability to deliver out working
models and that will be several that
will be at least one or two orders of
magnitude large
than what you would get the way we train
students at most universities here so
there's a big gap and unless your
students go and in turn in one of these
companies there's a big gap in how we
think of data now if you think of this
from a portfolio discovery point of view
just because data is big doesn't mean
the discoveries are important and that's
just important to keep in mind we talk a
lot about big data on the other hand in
terms of you know we run office you know
we run off as a data intensive computing
facility with you know several hundred
users several petabytes of data that is
scientific research data that's
available for discovery and I'm very
interested each year in this sort of the
quality of the science that comes you
know we have a each month we give away
computing hours over a petabyte of data
that's about a million dollars at Amazon
rates for each of our facilities and we
have several and then you can ask is if
we do a portfolio of we give this many
and so I think we have a couple million
core hours per facility and the question
is if we could give people for
data-intensive science say 300,000 or
half a million that month versus 10,000
as we do that in sort of a logarithmic
distribution in terms of coral is over a
petabyte of data you don't always get
the best science for the best ever from
the largest allocation and so you have
to sort of think of how that works and
sort of on the simple examples Netflix
is small data my definition of small
means it fits in memory so if net so the
the netflix prize which was a
million-dollar prize was for you know
seven years seven years of data over
half a million customers 100 million
movie ratings it was a very tough
statistical problem to solve but it was
small in the sense of fit into memory or
it does fit basically fit into a single
workstation it was designed that so they
could get 50,000 people to give them
free labor so I've already alluded
to this I want to talk just for a minute
about the origins of big data because I
think it's important before we go back
to the scientific data so this there's
two there's you know if you have data
and you can't manage it there are three
things you can do in general you can
change the hardware you could change the
software or you could change the
algorithm and then sometimes you can
change the problem you ask so if you
let's just look at how we change
hardware if we change hardware there are
two fundamental things we could do we
could do what's called scale-up we get
more specialized hardware by adding you
know specialized components or building
specialized devices or we could do
what's called scale out is we add more
of the devices and you you know when we
do hpc when we do large data we can take
any combination in this two dimensional
space and the interesting thing is I
mentioned there was a new source of data
which is large amounts of unstructured
data from the web and Google made a sort
of a series of interesting choices a
they decided that they would not follow
the sort of dominant paradigm at that
time which which was to use fairly
specialized compute with a scale up and
then use a sort of a software
infrastructure called message passing
instead they created what is now you
know called MapReduce and the Google
file system and we can use it in Hadoop
and they scaled out over commodity
components with a new software
infrastructure you know that's now sort
of part of a dupe and sort of that large
ecosystem you'd see it strata and that
was driven by computational advertising
and why did computational advertising
drive that it drove it for the simple
reason that if you made a small
improvement in computational advertising
you generated an additional billion
dollars and that you know every time you
had an additional billion dollars you
could save it to improve the hardware
and software stack and that created a
virtual asst loop and you know we're
going to hear later from the NSF but my
current understanding is in data
intensive science they spend less than a
billion dollars each year so that gave
that gave Google and some of these
others
a strong competitive advantage that
build year after year and created this
gap so you know it is now a hundred and
twenty billion dollar industry just
online advertising this is the inside of
Google's data center and this is
probably larger than the data centers
because it costs you know 400 to 500
million dollars then the data centers at
many universities the core software
infrastructure that came out it was
released in a series of papers that
conveniently came out when Google was
way working on the next generation
called the you know and it was a
software step with a very scalable file
system a very scalable way to work with
unstructured text data over it and then
a sort of very scalable database and
this is sort of a picture from a couple
years ago of the 120 billion dollar
industry that sort of his around
computational advertising and created
these new techniques and what this led
to a new way of talking about the size
of data you talked about the size of
data in terms of the number of megawatts
of the data center that controlled the
data so Facebook would say they're
building a new 30 megawatt data center
for say you know three hundred million
dollars and that would be to not only
hold the data but to analyze it and to
make it actionable so that's sort of the
unit you know say 10 to 15 megawatts is
the unit that they think of our data and
you know one of the themes I you know I
think it's interesting from a research
perspective is what is the unit that we
should think of data from a research
perspective so that we can make advances
that you know sort of unimaginable if we
don't conceptualize the problem right so
you know what is the analogy of this
unit so I want to talk a little bit
about analytics that's some self
tracking data from someone walking
around San Francisco so you know and the
reason I'm going to start with analytics
and then go to statistical models you
know in research what we
need to do is to take data integrate it
bring it together build statistical
models build distributors distichum
models and make discoveries so you know
it we go from data to statistical models
to discoveries to validation and we have
to do that in a very scalable way the
driving focus in industry is analytics
it's using you know in the jargon of the
fair credit for you know the fair credit
reporting act fcra is to do build
statistical models that are
statistically valid and empirically
derived from I pulled from these eight
this aasa the american statistical
association website their current
definition on their website of
statistics which I you know it's a much
more complicated story than this but
it's really focused around uncertainty
the you know some of the best advances
in big data come from statisticians but
you know there's a sort of a wide
variety within the statistical community
of what is big data real I mean in a
certain sense statisticians are right
when they say there is no such thing as
big data they either empirically derived
and statistically valid models or not on
the other hand as you get new sources of
data that are hundred or thousand times
larger than before the types of
statistical models you bill tend to be
different and it's sort of that tension
that sort of one of the interesting
focal points of the field right now this
is a very busy slide but occasionally
well what once on an airplane someone
asked me what I did and so I I tried to
explain what's happened in big data in
the last 40 years and it's all on this
slide and my view these days is there's
very few changes but once a decade we
get a change if you go to strada and
walk the the the and read the slogans of
the marketing people you feel that every
ten minutes there's a change and it came
from that venture bad company that's
going to be gone in ten minutes whose
technology will forever disappear but
from abroad
perspective there really hasn't been
that many changes so the first change is
what we call the field that's not
fundamental the second change is what
kind of conferences do you go to and how
nice are they when data mining came up
the conference's became much nicer than
much nicer places with much nicer hotels
than when it was called computationally
intensive statistics and recently what
big data the conferences are even nicer
so I think from that viewpoint there's
been a real events in the field because
the conferences are much nicer you know
if you read the Proceedings of one of
these conferences every you know every
year we get another 200 algorithms that
are a quote from the abstract innovative
and we're going to fundamentally change
the field on the other hand if you look
back the number of algorithms we get
that are really impactful we seem to get
one a decade or so sometimes we'll get a
new algorithm will take an old algorithm
over larger compute and change this name
say from neural net to deep learning but
we're still getting a new algorithm
every decade or so so you know we at
classification tree we have neural Nets
then we had classification regression
trees we'd support vector machines we
had a graph algorithm page rank and now
I don't know quite what the best
algorithm is I every time I go to one of
these conferences I try to take a vote
some people say it's believed mattress
maybe it's the sort of globally
distributed algorithms but we I'm sure
we have an algorithm and we're going to
figure out what it is and we'll look
back and you'll be obvious but you know
they're you know we you know we have a
lot of graph algorithms if pretty
fundamental is I talked about the
hardware sector software changes so I
talked about the doop doop really is
useful and it's being used in in
computing there are some issues with it
we got our we got postgres and then the
scale which we compute changes we went
from a computer to a beowulf cluster
that is what could fit in a rack to a
data center and I'm going to come back
to that because the one of the questions
is what's the analogy of a data
enter for data-intensive computing for
research and then if you around 2011
Google sort of released algorithms that
scale across multiple data centers this
is a very old problem but I just you
know I've talked a lot about things but
a lot of these ideas are very very old
you know this is a problem that Abraham
Walt worked down in World War two the
the question were was you know how do
you put additional armor on airplanes I
think most people have heard this but
it's it's worth thinking back about this
if you armor the airplanes were being
shot down down in World War two and if
you armor the whole plane you can't it
can't take off if you armor the wrong
places it doesn't help and if you armor
the right places you save lives so when
they collect the data you can see when a
plane comes back where the bullet holes
are so that you know the question is how
do you build a statistical model from
knowing where the bullet ours in an
airplane that will harden the airplane
and a lot more airplanes to keep back
and notice the validation is quite
simple if you put a constant number of
airplanes in the field and you assume
that the adversary is doing constant
behavior then your algorithm works if
the number of airplanes that comes back
increases and so a mall if you think
about this and Abraham wall did a model
where you want to put the bullet hole
the armor is where the bullet holes
aren't because those are the planes that
didn't get back and that he'd wrote a
paper about that that sort of is a nice
example what's called selection bias and
it's a nice example that you know you
still need to think no matter what the
software or hardware is you still really
need to think about the statistical and
algorithms and so that that that notion
is still very very valuable valuable
today it's just you know one of the
themes here is the bigger the data is
the easier it is to be stupid so I want
to stop about the historical origins of
big data you know is you know
it was first the first emergence in
terms of data mining came with the
emergence of the internet and the data
that came from click streams the second
second Renaissance with big data came
when people sort of analyze data at the
scale of a data center from what
Google's work was and talk about how
this looks like in science and most of
the time when you talk to people about
data they give you one example so this
is the example when a group of
researchers work together to come up
with one theme it costs a billion
dollars they get it funded maybe ten
billion dollars and they build one
instrument consisting of lots and lots
of small sensors and they produce data
and usually this takes ten years and at
the beginning of the ten years the
amount of data that's being produced
looks scary but by the end of the ten
years when the minced remains actually
built it turns out to be a fairly modest
amount of data if you know what you're
doing for example the LHC the Large
Hadron Collider produces the raw data is
about 15 petabytes it's multiplied
significantly as it's analyzed but the
raw data is 15 petabytes which is not a
big number today even though the drive
data is quite a bit beggar so on another
modality for for researchers is when you
have say hundreds to thousands of labs
producing sort of again instruments that
produce lots of data but it's sort of
you know it comes on the sort of midsize
machines that a lab might spend a
million dollars on this is a from a
couple years ago this is the sequencing
machine that sort of changed how
next-gen sequencing was done and you
know this is produced in aggregate a lot
of data across biology it's created a it
created a crisis that after only five to
eight years of discussion the biological
community created sort of a sea change
in how they do things I'm going to talk
a little bit about that you know in my
talk this is one of the areas i work in
you know so this happened a number of
years ago we discussed it for a number
of years and we're beginning to change
the way we look at large amounts of
genomics data something that's just
happening now is raise your hand if you
have any self tracking device okay raise
your hand if you know in addition to
yourself this is unrelated to talk I'm
just sort of curious if in addition to
yourself what third party companies um
you make use of your self tracking did
you any one track carefully who else has
their self tracking data raise your hand
okay that's a whole nother top but I'm
not going to talk about that so but this
is changing things I'm going to come
back to this one of the ways that people
think about this and you know i think
the Moore Foundation the sloan
Foundation really took a step in sort of
trying to get research universities to
think fundamentally about how to do
interdisciplinary science now the term
data science was introduced in industry
a number of years ago and it's also been
used for come something pretty different
in academic research for an emerging
discipline and again this is sort of the
morin sloan Foundation agreed sort of to
work together in an initiative around
data science and so this is the term i'm
going to use and so you can think of
data science is what comes to what
happens when I take deep math and stat
when I take deep computer science and I
take deep knowledge of a field and bring
them together the Moore Foundation and
the sloan Foundation talk about pie pie
pie shaped science pie-shaped science
means you have two legs you have a leg
into the discipline where you have a
deep knowledge of the discipline biology
social sciences or humanities and you
have a leg into math stad and computer
science I split them they don't and that
you could bring those things together to
create a new science and it's you know
this is like any number of Sciences in
starting with statistics to
computer science from an academic
discipline point of view it's still up
in the air whether this is a separate
discipline or whether there's a data
signs for physics of data science for
biology data signs for social signs you
know I think in some sense it doesn't
matter but there are interesting
challenges that are new in data science
horizontal data science vertical in
addition to sort of showing you nice
things that happen I also want to give
you a few cautionary tales how many had
salmon in the last week okay you may not
want to listen to the next so I again
this is pretty famous that's a picture
of a salmon of the type we're going to
talk about and they there was a this is
a poster that at a meeting i'll give you
a little more history I there's a lot of
research now where they put people into
fMRI machines show them pictures or tell
them stories or put chemicals into them
and see what parts of the brain light up
so in this experiment the the the
experiment was the following that's the
salmon they took a dead salmon and they
put the dead salmon into a functional
MRI machine and they applied exactly the
same algorithms that were used in about
twenty percent of the published
literature on these functional MRI and
emotional states and the voxels that
light up and they showed the dead salmon
pictures of happy humans and pictures of
unhappy humans and then they did it was
a controlled experiment and then they
identified the voxel in the brain that
identified happy humans because you know
that's presumably important and
understanding the the physiology and the
psychology of salmon and for some reason
the journal would not accept this for
publication but they did accept it as a
poster paper and you know you know these
you know the references on here
underneath on my slides you can see who
did it but
is this is a classic problem this is a
classic problem is you get more data
it's easy to ignore multiple independent
tests there's standard techniques to
normalize out significant levels when
you have multiple independent tests they
were treating each of the voxels was
independent asking if it arose above the
noise level and then you you know
without correcting for the number of
voxels which is thousands tens of
thousands and you know this problem
happens all the time it's a well-known
problem but that doesn't mean that the
papers that are published sort of are
aware of the problem so I've said this
several times I just thought it remind
you the bigger the data is easier it is
to do something stupid ah there were
only eight thousand voxels most a lot of
scientists are doing things and we have
millions or billions of models so you
really have to think through that you
don't want to make this simple voxel
mistake so um this is the sort of I want
to leave you with one or two thoughts to
think about the first thought is you
know new science you know I think a lot
about how to create you know I'm the
director of a center for data-intensive
sites at the University of Chicago there
are several other centers in data around
data at the University and you know our
Center and the others you know are
thinking together and you know what is
the academic discipline around around
data science and so my my point of view
on this is pretty simple is that a lot
of times a new discipline or new
modality of science is originates in an
instrument so in the same way
microscopes create you know gave us an
instrument to look at small things and
telescopes gave us an instrument to look
at far things you know we could ask what
is the instrument we need to look at
large data and um it's kind of
interesting to see what the resolution
increase was in some of these
instruments that created new science so
for example the the telescope gave you
about a 30 x increase in resolution of
the
should I the microscope gave you about a
250 increase in resolution over the
naked eye when I was starting my
career's people were distinguishing the
theoretical and experimental sciences
for what they called simulation science
where you would take a computer here a
prey computer and do things that
couldn't it be done before as best as I
can tell from looking at history the the
crate that first crate one which was a
great supercomputing and elegant in
design gave you a 10 to 100 x increase
in resolution in speed over the high end
mainframes at that time so if you do a
back of the envelope computation the
data center is being built by industry
give you at least a hundred fold
increase in resolution the ability to do
statistically valid models over data
than what we have in today's academic
most academic institutions so there are
sort of only three two conclusions one
you could say because of all the things
were exposed to in our diets these days
that were just not as smart as we were
in these other ages and that even though
we have an instrument with you know
maybe 10 x more resolution than the
prior instruments we're not going to
create a new signs or the other one is
there's a new science and we're going to
eventually figure it out it may not be
interesting you may be interesting but
there'll be something there so I think a
lot about how do we build these
instruments for ourselves and you know
this is sort of my bet for what the
instruments going to look like and where
I've spent the last 10 years or so
thinking about we don't have a name and
so because someone here made the mistake
of inviting me to give this talk I'm
going to call it a cyber pod this is
mainly to irritate everyone in the
audience so you'll come up after two
after the talk and tell me that's the
stupidest name that I've ever heard and
I why don't you call it you know
a tomato or something like that so I'm
going to call the cyber pod it's sort of
something you can afford to buy it's
about the price of what we pay for hpc
you know on sort of national scale hpc
efforts that you know do e and NSF fund
it's sort of you know sort of a that's a
picture of a container full of compute
so it's one or two computers that run a
hardware and software stack optimized
for doing scientific discovery over data
and it in 2004 when sort of the industry
did this it was at least giving you ten
to a hundred increase in the amount of
data you could build statistical models
and make discoveries over so one of the
problems I'm I sort of asked myself and
I'll tell you a little bit about it but
not much is if we had the right data
cyber pods and then just as there's a
database is a weighted to sort of you
know in one specialized scaled up
machine I you know the databases drive a
lot of science you can ask is there a
data pod that is a data software stack
over a cyber powder data that could
drive data science and new discoveries
you know as they come up so I think of
cyber pods and the software stack data
pods and so you know could we if we
could take all the nation or of the
world's cancer data and reanalyze it
every night you know what what would
that allow us to make in terms of
discovering treatment that we can't do
today and so this is not sort of absurd
you know in advertising they advertise
they analyze all of the you know may
they may advertise a billion individuals
response that you know in history to do
the best advertising algorithms for the
next day you know it's done in other
areas like advertising like
high-performance trading so the question
is if those disciplines can analyze all
of the data in the field and make a sort
of you know have a paradigm to move to
make discoveries each day why can't we
do that in in science
and so the this is the picture I have to
summarize the talk so far you know we
have this paradigm of where we get
really really smart scientists give them
a small amount of data and give them
years to make a discovery and they work
over they build they work over gigabytes
or terabytes of data that is about a
lots of compute and then the other end
you know you had knez this question is
their ability to work at the megawatt
level in cyber pods you would probably
build simpler models but you could redo
them every day you could reanalyze the
data every day and you know again I'm
not arguing that one side is better than
others I'm arguing that why not have a
portfolio of solutions in which you take
whatever you can from the whole spectrum
of solution space and not ignore one end
of the solution space and so this is
sort of the division and there you know
we have one person driving this whole
process that reanalyze a--'s the data
each day to make discoveries with new
data community all the text data all the
all the you know genomic data or the
associate clinical data so I now want to
talk about five trends I'm going to talk
about data Commons one of the terms we
can think of using for that right hand
side is a data Commons almost no one
talks about data Commons except for a
few isolated colleagues this is the
google trends for the term data Commons
if you compare that to data mining or
two big data this is a noise term that's
buried in the noise it doesn't even all
rise above the noise so the traditional
in bile in the gin the genomic Sciences
the paradigm has broken because
researchers who have a petabyte of
genomic data any researcher as a
petabyte of genomic data can afford to
have their own infrastructure can afford
to hire the data scientist the network's
I the engineers the data engineers etc
to analyze it so we were
Forest after only five years of
discussion to create sort of this other
paradigm in which we have a Commons and
here I'm defining the Commons where we
co-locate data storage and computing
infrastructure commonly used tools for
analyzing and sharing data to create a
resource for the for the community and
so the question is how do we create
comments at scale that can interoperate
with scientists own infrastructure that
could peer with each other and that can
change the way we do data science at
scale and I'm not going to talk about
them I build a series you know our team
and you know we created enough for
profit called the open Commons
consortium to do this has created a
series of these for the last several
years we created something called the
open science data cloud which has about
a petabyte of data on that I refer to
that before that was supported by the
Moore Foundation for three years we
created a something called the bio
Nimbus protected data cloud another
petabyte infrastructure which could hold
large cancer genomes and clinical data
from large cancer projects funded by the
NCI we're building and it's in beta
testing and so if you guys are bored and
don't have anything to do you could beta
test this this the NCAA genomic data
Commons is an infrastructure that's
going to hold research data from all
National Cancer Institute funded
projects and any NCI funded researcher
and they as part of their funding are
required to put their data into a
commons and it's the NCI genomic data
Commons it's in beta now be released in
a sort of one level released in November
and another release in May for general
use and then the NOAA is also has a
comments for all their data and we're
building one of them and then Amazon
Google IBM Microsoft are also building
Commons where really ours is focused on
the research community this is a picture
of the genomic data Commons it has today
to petabytes growing 25 petabytes of
data we we analyze all that data so it's
as a common analysis the data that comes
in
has by and large be been analyzed either
by single research groups or by the
Centers that put them together so this
is a reanalysis of all the data and
we're designing a system that could real
reanalyze all NCI funded data you know
every few months we'd like to scale up
the infrastructure so we could do it
even faster than that we downloaded the
two petabytes of data and process it in
real time did QC redid the alignment and
etc and this is a picture from a part of
a day at the bottom or the this of those
lines is a file at the bottom the length
the time is horizontal and it's a length
of time it took us to process it from it
files there almost a terabyte in size
that we downloaded to files that are
megabytes and gigabytes I think it's a
half a million files it we brought it in
that sort of eight or nine gigabits per
second for weeks to analyze it and then
you know there's this view that the you
know I'd like to do things that are
simple so once you have data that no one
else has done you could do pretty simple
statistical models so this is a
statistical model we built where the the
gray or add no carcinoma to particular
type of lung cancer the purple or
squamous cell carcinoma we took we took
the RNA seek data we did principal
components analysis in about 400
dimensions and we just built some simple
statistical models and the green are
things that seem to be misclassified
under this analysis it's about ten
percent in there there's a drug Avastin
that works from one that doesn't work
for the other it actually shortens your
life at about half if it's missed
applied so this is an example of a
relatively simple statistical model that
could only be done when you have enough
data that has a huge impact that's
relatively simple to do as long as you
have access to the data to do
statistical analysis at scale I want to
talk about the second trend this is
really analytics of things people and
places this is a we have a
Ben sensors that we're putting into
Chicago their number of instrumenting
cities this is the idea that to
understand urban science let's
instrument a city that's a conceptual
version because the actual sensors in
chicago or much uglier but that's what
they thought it would look like before
they actually built it there are
actually putting sensors into all sorts
of things so you could put sensors in to
wait in to waste bins and other things
inset in city so cities are going to be
instrumented and produce lots of data
that's going to change how we think
about urban science I think most of
people have this but there's also people
are going to producing lots of data the
data that will change how we think about
social science and health science and
places are going to generate data this
is you know certain many cars have
phones or probe devices that emit probes
the Purple's where people break and you
could sort of see that you could observe
that the cars that don't break in the
right place can't navigate the curve so
i sent i use the term coral space greek
corals for place to be the analytics
associated with place so as you have
anal you know things giving off data
people giving off data you can annotate
space in interesting ways and here we
could sort of if we see a car not going
not going slow enough you could inform
the car and form the driver that if they
don't slow down they're not going to be
able to navigate that and this is a very
simple model that is clear to how to
build once you have enough data my
second trend is my third trend is we're
not doing sometimes very deep computer
science for big data and I'd like just
to remind people we've talked about the
software stack that sort of does new
programming paradigms I haven't talked
about the networking stack the data
centers have new types of networks but I
do want to mention that one of the most
powerful things we have in computer
science is the ability to use languages
so right now we think of computer
scientists as heroes
that can do whatever they want with no
discipline and as long as they get an
answer out we're happy but why not give
them tools and force them to use the
tools for example there are languages
for graphics my colleague Leland
Wilkerson wrote a sort of a very
influential book called the grammar of
graphics so that when we did
visualization and exploratory data
systems we can on you know we could
really do that with grammar so that we
can you know manipulate the language
that describes the graphics instead of
always manipulating the graphics i spent
about 15 years of my life building
models for analytics so that at scale
when we have lots of models etc like
that we work with the models using a
language it was first a predictive model
markup language now the portable format
for analytics and this allows you to
scale up to sort of cyber pods and data
centers how you build analytics at scale
and you know we you know you if you
think about visualization I pull out d3
but there are others that allow you to
sort of describe what you want to do not
how you want to visualize the fourth
trend is you know they're going to be a
lot of policy there are policies and
they're going to create other policies
that are going to encourage people to
make data available the government is
now asked to make data available under
the exact order 1364 to form a 13 and
the guidance from OMB that led to the
NOAA which was the first agency to sort
of operationalize this in terms of a
crater that is a cooperative agreement
that allowed our consortium and IBM
Microsoft and Google to sort of partner
with Noah to make the 20 petabytes to go
you know to take have access to any of
the 20 petabytes to make it available to
in our case researchers to the other
companies to research mainly companies
but that was driven by the OMB
initiative there's also initiatives for
preservation and others you know
thoughts about reproducibility so
there's a sea change coming and we don't
really have the infrastructure to do
that and then I'm going to talk about
the last trend and then leave time for
44 is that clock right okay good use a
lot of times they put me in places where
the clocks are wrong for just just
challenge me um so you know early my
career I did math and I you know the
nice thing about math it doesn't apply
to anyone the last little bit of my
career I I'm a little more interested in
as you do things like data science can
it apply to anyone and so you know I'm
going to talk about what I call
translational data science so the term
translational was created you know a
number of years ago around this notion
that there was a big gap between how
long a you know a lag between how long
it took a basic discovery in biology or
medicine to go from the lab to the to
the patient and so you know I put sort
of the you know if we think of this as
informatics in general we have bio
informatics at the molecular cellular
level imaging informatics clinical
information a clinical informatics
public health informatics but we have
translational in each of those things
and so you know translational
informatics is something that people
have been struggling with for ten years
and so one of the things that's been
motivating us in our Center is what you
might call translational data science
that is if you don't just think about
the discovery but you think about how to
accelerate the impact of that discovery
on populations or our patients or you
know on society you can ask you know
there's sort of this notion that we
spent all our time thinking about the
hardware software and modeling but most
of it is most of the translational
effort is on setting up the
infrastructure getting the data on one
side and then deploying the model and
checking it and making an action on the
other and the actual modeling is a very
small component so if you want to
optimize the translational
impact you have to have things like
languages for deployment that's why we
had created portable format for
analytics you have to create standard
systems like cyber pods to take care of
the data so that you can impact the
whole thing and so we think of the data
engineering data science and
applications in this case to genomics
analysis of medical records etc where we
can get discoveries diagnosis and
therapeutics out as being sort of a way
to do translational data science and you
know these are you know this is some
example of that where we're trying to
take large amounts of environmental
electronical medical records and try to
understand how we could make impacts and
this is the distribution of two diseases
one is clearly related to the physical
environment that turned out we just
analyze the data is about 100 million
medical records the top turns out to be
a well-known this and we ranked ordered
all about a thousand diseases by icd-9
codes from those that have most geo
spatial variation to those at least then
we did we were doing a simple classifier
to ask it is the geo spatial variation
due to environmental so she can have a
socio-economic structural like payer
provider or other and the top is
something is clearly physical when you
look at it the middle it's not so
obvious what that is but that's really
social economic driven and then you can
see things that are payer providers on
because they split very much on the sort
of jurisdictional lines so I want to end
with five challenges so I think the one
that's probably most to my heart and
maybe the hardest is this sort of way
that Phil Anderson a Nobel Prize winning
physicist asked the question he
summarized his work in statistical and
in basically solid-state physics as
really being you know concerned with the
question is at scale you know as you go
add more and more things are there new
emergent behavior that's really
different there's this famous science
article if science article and 72 called
is more different and I think to me this
is the fundamental question a lot of
statisticians believe
Eve and you know maybe and are certainly
right at some level that you know there
is no such thing as big data there is
only good and bad statistics on the
other hand at a feminine logical level
you sort of believe as you go to scale
certain phenomena that appear that just
don't appear and that certainly is the
case in solid-state physics and to me
the question data science is one of the
outstanding questions is what
discoveries can we make in data science
that you've shown emergent properties
that just aren't there at smaller scale
um the second challenge of alluded to of
sometimes this one I've been working out
one of the reasons we created the
protect the the comments for genomic and
clinical data is what's and this is part
of you know the this you know doing a
million genomes was part of the
presidential precision ille medicine
initiative is you know if you know it's
it at a thousand dollars it's roughly a
billion dollars of sequencing but if
there's about a terabyte of data as we
get more data for patients a million
terabytes is a thousand petabytes is an
exabyte that's something that is sort of
outside of what we could easily do in
science today the question is you know
how do we but it would probably
fundamentally change because cancer and
other diseases are about rare very eight
combinations of rare variants we don't
have the statistical power and we
thought we did but every time we think
we do we're sort of sort of surprised by
the complexity of cancer but a million
you know you hope that with a million
genomes an exabyte of data that you
would have an understanding but
understanding statistics at that level
is really a big challenge um the other
one I'm going to say is how do we create
tools for research communities data pods
and pod basis that allow us to easily
give open-source infrastructure that's
simple and easy to manage to researchers
so they could do so they have
instruments for discovery at the scale
that data science sometimes
ass I actually had ten challenges but I
only had time for five so it was a
little as we get to challenge four and
five sometimes they're above and below
the line I think this is an interesting
problem it's we know how to deal with
the billion feature vectors we know how
to do with million dimensions I don't
think we have a very good understanding
of how we can automate semi automate the
production of a billion statistical
models and make sure that we can
validate them and understand so one of
the things I'm interested in how do we
scale up our ability to work with very
very large amount numbers of models and
then again this is if you look back
think back into some things I've said
about languages the infrastructure pods
it's really this is part and parcel of
it and the last one we have something
called HCI human-computer interaction I
think it might be interesting to imagine
what a human data science interaction is
you know initially it was the data it
was the data science and statistician
doing everything there was a period of
time when the statistician did nothing I
actually think there's sort of a nice
interesting middle ground where the data
scientists tears these very large
systems and you know we it's a sort of a
good time you know people of Mechanical
Turk they have a lot of things but you
know how can we bring the human back
into this loop to scale things up and so
I up every year or so I post a blog post
so I'm due for one so I'm going to put
the the nine or ten challenges up there
and some references but that's all i had
to say for today
you
[Applause]